With the Christmas season upon us,
let's recap the year today,
both for the wider world as well as the
great community that we've built here at
the Rubin report.
Note,
I did say Christmas season.
They're not holiday season or winter
spectacular or whatever else the PC
crowd wants us to say these days.
The fact is that the wide majority of
people in the United States do celebrate
Christmas and whether you celebrate it
or not,
there is goodness to be had in the
spirit of the season like being kind to
your fellow man when someone wishes you
a merry Christmas.
That is not an affront to Hanukah,
Kwanza,
Festivus,
or the cycle of the planets.
In many cases,
probably most cases wishing someone a
merry Christmas is more of just an
acknowledgement of the holiday season
rather than some sort of religious
edict.
Of course,
by the same token,
if you're offended that someone wished
you happy holidays instead of Merry
Christmas,
perhaps your offense meter is out of
whack.
To the point is that it's the end of the
year in 2016 has been particularly
divisive,
so let's try to find some joy in one
another and wish good tidings even to
people who weren't that good to us this
past year on the world front.
20 16 will go down as one of the
craziest years ever.
Donald trump becoming the next president
of the United States was clearly the
biggest story,
but England choosing brexit instead of
staying in the European Union as well as
the continued humanitarian disaster in
Syria.
We'll all have major impacts as we move
into 2017 and beyond.
More than anything else though.
Twenty 16 taught us that at least here
in the west,
the power is still with the people in
both trump's win and the brexit vote.
The vast majority of the media,
the elites,
the establishment,
and the money was on the other side.
Yet despite this,
the people rose up and change the course
of the world with their votes.
Now,
you may not like the results of either
of those two events and you may not be
happy with the electoral college or with
the tactics of the brexit tiers,
but you have to acknowledge that there
is something amazing and the ability of
people in a western democracy to truly
control their own destiny.
Most people on Earth would give anything
to have this much control over the
system that they live in.
In fact,
the revolutions which swept throughout
the Middle East over the past few years,
we're done with the hopes that the
people could one day have as much sway
over their leaders as we have in the
West right now.
While these revolutions haven't worked
out as planned,
the seeds of freedom had been planted
and even if Egypt,
Libya,
and obviously Syria,
rn is free as we want them to be.
The ideas of freedom have taken root
thanks to the Internet.
Most of us now walk around with the
world in our pocket.
We're connected in incredible ways,
changing the world right in front of us.
No longer do we have to get our
information from only a few sources.
Now,
any and all of us can be a source of
information all over the globe.
Of course,
this barrier to entry creates other
problems like who can we actually trust,
but I would always veer on the side of
having access to more information than
less information.
Just look at how the mainstream media
has reacted to the trump win.
Did they offer us any real introspection
and reevaluate their tactics and
methods?
No,
of course not.
Instead they doubled down on identity
politics and name calling and at the
same time the mainstream media told us
that anything that's sanctioned by them
is fake news.
When the very people who invented fake
news or warning you about fake news,
well you know the tide is beginning to
turn.
The issue is that I've tried to
highlight over the past year from the
importance of free speech to having
honest political discourse really
encompass everything which moved our
world in 2016,
the stifling of free speech by using
cries of racism and bigotry.
Shut down honest conversation about
relevant topics like Islamism and
immigration.
There's a direct line from that stifling
of hard but important conversations that
led us to brexit and trump.
Couple the inability or unwillingness to
have difficult conversations about
important issues with the hyper partisan
fighting that we now have where people
literally drop friends and family
members over political disagreements and
you have a toxic stew.
Having honest conversations without
resorting to demagoguery will be trump's
biggest challenge and it's one that I
hope that he will succeed at.
We know that trump's good at winning,
but will he be gracious enough to
understand that his win isn't just for
himself and his supporters,
but also for the people who voted
against him,
even if they're still shouting about it?
Right?
This very second.
I really believe that if trump focuses
on the economy and infrastructure,
if he doesn't get us involved in
unnecessary military conflicts and if he
unleashes the tech sector,
that we could have another American
renaissance.
These are huge gifts amongst many other
ifs,
but right now if you root for trump to
fail,
then you root for our country to fail.
More important than anything else.
If we had been able to have more honest
and enlightened conversations in 2016
than perhaps the world would feel a
little more sensible than it does right
now.
You know,
it's funny.
We don't like when people discriminate
on the basis of religion,
which is simply a set of ideas,
but we have no problem when people
discriminate based on political
affiliation,
which also is just a set of ideas.
Tolerance of different opinions will be
our biggest national challenge in 2017.
Accepting that not everyone agrees with
us all the time and not only is that
okay,
but it's actually preferable will be
something that we all have to put into
action in this coming year.
We had our share of group think in 2016
because everyone seemed to go into their
little bubbles.
Hopefully 2017 is where we burst them
and we see what happened.
Joining me this week is Tim Ferriss.
Tim is no stranger talking to people
from every walk of life and from every
corner of the globe.
His podcast,
the Tim Ferriss show,
is over 100 million downloads and he's
chatted with people from Sam Harris and
Arnold Schwartzenegger to Tim Robbins
and Kevin Costner.
He's been described as the oprah of
podcasting and his new book tools of
titans is a compilation of some of the
best habits he's learned from his
various guests.
It seems fitting to veer into the end of
2016 as an interviewer interviewing an
interviewer.
If 2016 was the year of outrage,
then let's have 2017 be the year of the
conversation.
Joining me this week is an author and
entrepreneur,
a speaker,
and a master of all kinds of cool
things.
Some have called him the Oprah of audio.
Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
The Oprah of audio.
How do you like that moniker?
Well,
it must be the striking resemblance that
we have.
A,
I'm flattered by it.
I think that,
uh,
couldn't ask for more flattering
moniker,
although I think it still remains to be
seen if I can live up to that.
But it's been a trip and audio,
my experimental career in audio.
Have you ever given your audience cars?
Has everyone got in the car yet?
I have,
I've not done cars yet.
I've done a tee shirts,
mushroom coffee,
and a handful of other lower ticket
items.
Sometimes sardines,
canned sardines.
Uh,
but not yet.
Cars haven't made my way up to the cars
yet.
Yeah.
Sardines.
Very good for you.
And we're going to talk about some of
the things that you've given away in
some of the ideas that you,
uh,
that you push amongst your crowd.
Uh,
I was feeling undue pressure to ask the
right questions this week.
I think I'm all right at this,
but I thought,
all right,
Tim Ferriss,
he's known as asking good questions.
So the first question I'm going to go,
I'm going to go abroad with you for a
number one.
For the person that's watching this,
that has no idea who tim ferriss is,
if that,
if such a person exists,
what would you say is,
what is the mission of Tim Ferriss?
Tim Ferriss is a self experimenter who
runs experiments with the help of some
of the world's top performers.
Could be scientists,
could be athletes,
could be entrepreneurs,
ceos,
etc.
And then writes about the results so
that readers can have the cliff notes
version and that is really the gist of
it.
Out All of my experiments work out as
planned,
which make for entertaining reading and
a tragic injury on my part in some
cases,
but generally speaking I view myself as
as an experimentalist and a teacher,
not primarily writer and it is my job to
push the extremes and do all of that
heavy lifting so that my readers do not
have to.
When did you get interested in all of
this?
Was there a point like when you were in
high school or junior high,
were you always the limits of what you
could do and trying to figure out what
was next
in a sense?
I was starting probably around age 13,
14 and that was competitive wrestling.
uh,
I was put into kiddie wrestling when I
was probably 10 by.
My mom was very hyperactive and other
moms recommended that as a way to
diffuse things and a drain my batteries.
But I was also a very,
very small.
I was born premature and I was very
small up until about sixth grade and in
this case you had weight classes so the
60 pound weaklings could battle the
other 60 pound weaklings and someone
could come out on top and as I moved
further ahead and got better at
wrestling,
I realized there was a huge advantage in
a recording your workouts and training
approaches be recording the technical
practice and see getting very good at
weight cutting,
so actually become very,
very good at cutting weight,
which I don't recommend.
It's not a healthy thing to do because
it's primarily dehydration,
but
you literally would not drink water
right for,
for.
Was it just a couple of days before and
then right before the match you'd like
down hold?
Yeah,
no water.
you,
you dehydrate and then rehydrate.
so I would actually cut from my senior
year one 78 to 1:52
is 26 pounds twice a week and that was
done between 12 and 18 hours.
To do that without ever having some type
of organ failure,
you have to get a good basic
understanding of sodium,
potassium.
how all of these things work together so
you don't really,
really damage yourself,
but I saw the rewards there from
documentation and experimentation and
then later to start applying that to
everything.
Yeah.
so in a weird way you were sorta,
you were kind of like a scientist as a
kid.
YOu were using your own body as the,
As the experiment and you were
documenting everything and kind of
seeing what worked.
Yeah,
that's right.
And actually went to high school with
the son of george plimpton,
who I only really came to appreciate
later as one of the first,
I guess you could call them a fully
immersive participatory journalists who
would try to play a professional
football game or box someone like a
sonny liston for a few rounds and then
write about the experiment about the
experience.
so this is,
this is not a new tradition.
A lot of people have done it,
but I think that I was one of the first
two at least popularized really taking
the physical component,
uh,
to an extreme degree.
But all the,
all the principles can be applied or
many of them can be applied to the world
of business.
They can be applied to the world of say
education.
The language learning the principles
are,
are very flexible.
Yeah.
So the four hour work week I think was
really the first thing that put you on
the map in a,
in a bigger sense.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I saw you a couple of weeks ago,
we had dinner.
I was worried about,
you know,
can I eat carbs in front of him or
whatever.
You were very nonjudgmental.
I appreciate that.
Um,
but for me,
I've been building this studio for the
last month.
I have had one of the craziest month in
my 40 years on earth.
I mean,
my eating habits have been terrible.
I literally haven't been to the gym and
um,
I just have not had a moment to,
to get any of that.
Right.
So what would you say to somebody that's
really when you're in the thick of it,
when life is actually just you're just
thrown in the river and you just gotta
go,
you can't fight the current and it's for
something that you want to do.
How would you recommend I manage some of
this,
this time and stress and all this stuff?
Well,
I would think that there are a few
different questions that I tend to
depend on in situations like that.
So for instance,
I mean I just,
I just completed a 700 page book in less
than four months and that's for me
unheard of.
All of my book projects had been three
years.
And you're working with.
Yeah,
the font,
it was like four words.
The page laid out beautifully and the,
the question that I returned to
frequently was what would this look like
if it were easy or what might this look
like if it were easy and brainstorming
seemingly absurd answers to questions.
Like,
what if I had to write this book in a
week?
I knew I wasn't going to attempt to
write it in a week,
but what if I had to add a gun against
my head and you can,
you can generate ideas that fall outside
of your current constraints that you've
applied,
if that makes any sense.
So in the case of building a studio,
in the case of say,
recording my podcast,
I very often am trying to prevent the,
I think very natural tendency towards
complexity and sophistication,
which,
uh,
oftentimes I think that whether it's
building a studio or writing a book and
there are benefits to this,
I don't want to discount the value of
what I'm about to say.
But I remember when I was writing my
second book and I told an author friend
of mine,
well,
90 percent done.
And he goes,
well,
congratulations.
You only have half left.
And uh,
sometimes it makes sense to put in that
last 10 percent.
Other times it makes sense to actually
get started and experiment with less
than perfect.
Uh,
and that's,
it's very context dependent,
but those would be a few,
a meta kind of approaches that have
taking.
And then you,
you can also apply certainly things like
the 80 slash 20 principle to just about
anything,
so you have credos law or the 80 slash
20 principle,
which you could look at it a few
different ways.
So one is you could ask yourself,
for instance,
what 20 percent of the equipment or
activities or infrastructure gives me 80
percent of the output that I want in the
case of a studio.
right?
Conversely,
if you've already been working on it for
say a week and you have three weeks
scheduled left,
you could ask yourself what are the 20
percent of gear or activities,
uh,
or personnel for that matter who are
causing 80 percent or more of the
emotions that I do not want.
And,
and that could create a not to do list
or a four now omit list to be assessed
in the future list.
So those are some of the,
the tools and frameworks that I would
tend to use in a situation like that or
from juggling my real sort of financial
career as,
as a,
as tech investor.
And then I stopped doing that about a
year and a half ago,
but in fact the matter is I have a
portfolio of say 70 companies.
That's a lot to manage in and of itself.
Um,
so these,
these are the types of questions that I
will ask myself and people who are
running these fast,
growIng companies very often.
How hard is it for you to delegate some
of that stuff?
So 70 tech companies,
there's a lot going on it,
I would assume,
basically virtually impossible to really
know the nitty gritty of every one.
I'm sure you don't even want to know the
nitty gritty of everyone.
And some are probably more passion
projects than others.
How easy is it for you to delegate some
of that and have a core group of people
to trust that can advise you?
I is,
when it comes to the angel investing,
I delegate very little.
I do have a small team who will work
with companies on very specific aspects
of say,
conversion optimization or user
interface,
things like that based on my direction.
But I've also phased how I at least
historically have done investments that
I only have of those 70 say five to 10
maximum who actively need my help at any
given point in time.
And the the one of the signs that
accompany is probably going to do poorly
is this,
if they constantly want your input,
they should.
They should be spending a high
percentage of that time having their own
opinions and in building mode and if
they're,
if they're constantly in a sense
procrastinating,
doing the work by asking for advice,
then you,
you generally take that as a red flag
because the thing is you're going to go
sideways.
But I,
I tend to face things that I only have
five to 10 activity any given point in
time.
And then I have a,
I would say a process that I impose on
each of those initial interactions.
So then I'm checking boxes and those
required typically a fair amount of
homework and introspection on the part
of the companies.
So I'm able to pace it in that respect.
It's very rare that I have more than
five companies or a five to 10.
Let's say come to me in a given month
with any type of time sensitive
requirement.
They're,
they're,
they're generally pretty thoughtful
about it and since I'm working in the
venture backed tech arena,
the best founders and ceos understand
how to interact with say a board of
directors and they would treat me not
quite as a member of the board of
directors certainly,
but they would understand how to best
utilize my time because they've done
that with board members already.
So as the tech guy,
how realistic is silicon valley show?
Oh,
the show.
I think it's spot on and a lot of ways.
Oh yeah.
I think.
I think it is very accurate in a lot of
respects,
which is why I find it so funny,
especially the second season,
although a lot in the first season as
well.
It is,
it is a uncannily accurate and in a lot
of respects,
and I don't take that as a bad thing.
I mean silicon valley is a quirky part
of the world,
but if it weren't quirky it wouldn't be
what it is.
It wouldn't be able,
I think,
to produce a lot of what it produces and
uh,
it's a weird place.
It has its flaws and its foibles,
but that's true of any location where
you have,
tend to have a mano conversation.
Right?
So if you go to Washington dc and you
have the motto conversation of
government and politics,
it's a weird,
weird place.
You go to say los angeles and you have
in many places the mano conversation of
entertainment.
That's a really weird,
weird environment.
I would argue weirder in some ways.
Then silicon valley and silicon valley,
of course,
it's texts that you have just as much
weirdness and a ecentric behavior to put
it politely as,
as all of those other places.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if you'll know the answer
to this,
but how monotheism mono be monotheistic
monolithic.
How about that?
A monotheistic would be something else.
How monolithic is sort of the political
think up in silicon valley,
do you think?
Because I,
you know,
over the election,
uh,
there were all these articles written
about peter teal.
He's the bad boy of silicon valley.
He doesn't think like everybody else.
And it seemed odd to me that they were
like,
well,
we can find one guy now.
I know he likes putting himself out
there and he obviously he spoke at the
rnc and he's backed trump and all that
stuff.
But is the,
is the political group think they're as
strong as as it seems to be?
I would say so.
It's a very.
Well,
I may be.
I may be a getting a little above my pay
grade in terms of,
of of subject areas.
This is not an area of expertise for me,
but
there is such an echo chamber I think in
silicon valley in many respects or just
in the,
in the bay area that it's easy for
everyone there to pat themselves on the
back in a very aggressive,
hyper liberal slash progressive way and
look down their nose at what they would
perceive as the rest of America.
And it's,
it's a noxious and sanctimonious and a
lot of respects and is also very,
very counterproductive.
So it's,
I mean,
I don't know how far we want to go down
the political rabbit hole.
We can do it,
but I mean,
there,
there's part of me that feels like,
you know,
I'm probably,
I'm going to get myself into trouble
here,
but it's a spaghetti.
It's a smugness that I think is part of
the reason why,
and this is someone speaking as I would
say,
you know,
very socially,
at least liberal person,
uh,
that smugness is part of the reason they
got their teeth kicked in.
Yeah.
They,
they,
they went in really underestimating the
opposition and sort of carp launch
writing off everybody who was leaning
towards trump as stupid or ignorant or
racist even worse or fill in the blank,
whatever it might be.
And that created a huge blind spot,
I think.
yeah.
Gigantic blind spot underestimating the,
uh,
the flaws in polling methodology I think
was also something that,
that from a rational perspective,
if for instance,
I mean,
I know my brothers is a effectively a
phd.
He's finishing his dissertation in,
in statistics.
He called trump months before it
happened.
Really?
He's,
oh yeah,
he's absolutely going to win.
And uh,
he is not,
he would not position himself as a
conservative in any,
in any respect.
Uh,
Scott Adams,
creator of dilbert,
also on my podcast called it kinda blow
for blow how it was going to go down.
Yeah.
And it's,
um,
it's,
I,
I do think that,
just to get back to your question that
there is a lot of group think in silicon
valley and the,
the irony of that I think is Worth
underscoring because it's supposed to be
this think different place and yet it
has all of its own baggage and group
think just like every other place that
has a mono conversation.
Uh,
and then you have someone like peter
teal a couple long enough.
I've spent time with peter.
He's not a close friend,
but I've had dinner at a,
been a group dinners with him a number
of times and he's a smart guy.
So the first thing that I thought to
myself when he came out in support of
trump wasn't how could he do this?
It was,
what am I missing?
What am I missing?
There's something I'm missing here.
Because teal is not need,
certainly in my experience,
very impulsive,
short term thinker.
That's just not,
that's just not him.
So,
uh,
I,
from the very outset I was like,
what am I missing?
Like is there some tWenty year long bed
or short bed that he's making right now?
What,
what aspects of this am I missing?
A.
But yes,
I do think there's a lot of group
thinking silicon valley,
which is,
it just creates blind spots and opens
the door for then not only disruptive
technology to say trying to cut out off
a yahoo or someone like that at the
knees,
but it creates,
I think,
vulnerabilities in,
in a,
in a political,
in a political landscape.
And I'm far beyond that.
Yeah.
I'm curious because you prefaced all of
that by saying that you don't want to
talk about standing above your pay
grade,
which I think is an interesting way to
preface that.
You,
you know,
you obviously are thought of as a
thought leader,
but politics has become so toxic that I
could sense you were choosing your words
very carefully there because you don't
want to upset anybody by slightly
misspeaking or slightly misquoting
someone or something like that.
What do you make of the general tenor of
dialogue in the country right now?
I think it's ludicrous and self
defeating.
I think that everyone should reread
fahrenheit 4:51
because if some people might recall
reading it in high school and they think
of this,
uh,
did they tyrannical government that is
forcing the burning of books and of
course the,
some of the main characters,
but you have these firemen who are in
charge of burning books.
And what many people cease to realize if
they reread that book,
which they will rediscover,
is that it was actually the people in
the beginning who started the burning of
the books.
Books that would offend any minority.
And I don't mean that in a racial group,
a racial sense,
but a minority population,
uh,
began to be burned.
And this is,
this is very,
very,
very dangerous.
And I think a very slippery slope where
you have effectively,
and uh,
I've,
I've seen a number of people remark to
this effect,
you have the majority of smart people
who could discuss a topic and have the
necessary uncomfortable conversation and
a rational way opting out because the
personal downside is so high that it
outweighs in the minds of these people
who could actually catalyze a lot of
good.
The,
the,
the collective longterm good is not
sufficiently compelling to take an
almost guaranteed short term or I should
say immediate,
not short term.
It could be very longterm,
but immediate personal hit.
Uh,
so I,
I think it's terrible.
I think it's at,
I think,
I think it's the,
the biggest,
the thing that scares me most of the
United States right now is,
is by far and away not what some leader
from on high would necessarily do to us.
It is what we were already doing to
ourselves.
And that is disinvited brilliant people
from speaking at universities because
they might,
they might offer opinions or positions
that would make students uncomfortable.
That's the whole point.
I mean,
how are you going to handle
macroaggression in real life if you
can't handle different opinions from
your own in an academic setting?
It's ludicrous.
So that,
uh,
yeah,
I get,
I get pretty lit up about this because I
think it's,
I think it's a very insidious problem
that is in some ways being viewed as a
solution and it is certainly,
I think not a beneficial in the long
term at all.
Yeah,
you hit on a bunch of my wheel house
stuff there,
but I think the most interesting piece
of that is that what you're saying is
basically good people who could really
change the world,
who could change people's minds,
get involved,
that they're not because of the personal
cost.
How would,
how can we unfurl that?
I mean,
I've tried to bring on people here and,
and get to some of this,
but I know and I can see it sometimes
with guests and I'm sure you can too.
You get to a place where they can't go
any further.
They just,
there's a cost of them talking about
something,
even if they're an expert in that,
where they go,
now I'm veering past that red line and I
can get into some trouble.
So how do we bring that back?
For those of us that want to have
responsible conversations and open
discourse?
well,
there's,
there's a word that I've been
experimenting with a creating odd words
and inserting them into the common
vernacular for two years.
Now a one has made some rounds.
This is,
this is one I did just for fun,
but you'll,
you'll see where I'm going here.
So it's,
it's dell adultery until adultery is
when a significant other or you watch a
tv show that you've agreed to watch
together.
You watch it by yourself.
That's,
that's tele daltrey.
So that.
But that traveled.
Here's the important point.
So that term traveled all over the place
and then we were.
I was actually sitting in an airport
overseas with my mom and she'd say,
oh,
here's a funny word you would like.
And it was in a magazine and it was tele
is tele adultery.
This is where the I had created.
So there's a word that I currently,
I think that it's very,
if you look at the,
the actors in this,
a suffocation of free speech or
discouragement at the very least have an
open discourse.
You have,
I think on many sides what some people
have called social justice warriors,
a who throw around terms like racist,
sexist,
bigot of many different types,
very loosely in those terms,
uh,
can have lasting damage even if there's
no evidence associated with them.
Uh,
so the accusation itself becomes the
conviction and the term social justice
warriors not neutral in the sense that
it sounds positive.
So there really isn't any linguistic
punishment,
a equivalent to say racist that would
discourage someone from behaving in such
a haphazard fashion and in a way that
can destroy careers,
marriages,
you name it.
Uh,
so the term that I came up in a
conversation with eric weinstein,
really,
really brilliant mathematician,
physicist,
was this term big,
a tier that I thought of.
So big.
A tier is clearly not a good thing.
It sounds terrible.
And it is someone who calls others
bigots for personal gain and that
personal gains,
you could just be attention,
it could be absolving themselves of
guilt,
it could be clickthroughs,
it could be yellow journalism and
irresponsible media just aiming for
clickbait and click throughs.
So I think that if big adhere were work
to become a real term applied to people
who use these terms very loosely,
that it sounds silly,
but I do think that words are what we
lack right now are affective words and
labels to discourage this,
uh,
this behavior.
So that's one that has come to mind is
big a tier,
I don't think until we have some type of
disincentive from behaving in a way that
cauterizes or just stymies free speech
that we're not going to get very far.
So if the humans just respond to
incentives,
I don't think humans are necessarily
bad.
We're just creatures that respond to
incentives.
So you have to figure out how to set
this,
the carrot or the stick sufficiently to
get the behavior you want.
Yeah.
Are you saying it's almost like every
other animal on this earth?
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Incredible.
well I love the phrase big here and I've
used it a little bit,
but you know,
we're going to try something as of
today.
I'm going to use a little bit of what
they call the tim ferris effect,
which is that when you know,
when you've had people on your show,
usually their book sales go up or their
clicks go up or whatever it is.
So we'll try a little something.
I'll push out big a tier from today
going forward and like fee if we get a
little tim ferris effect on that because
you're right,
you say social justice warrior,
it sounds like a good thing for someone
that doesn't know really the
underpinnings of what's of what's going
on there.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Let's,
let's,
let's do it.
I'll love for it.
Alright,
so let's shift a little bit to your
podcast because we are both creatures of
the interview.
How am I doing so far,
by the way?
You're doing great.
Okay.
Alright,
very good.
So did you always think of yourself as
an interviewer?
What made you want to do the podcast in
that form?
I always thought of myself as an
experimenter and a teacher.
I always thought I was going to teach
ninth grade actually because I was very
much influenced by mentors at I think a
very critical,
critical juncture.
A around that age.
The ninth,
10th grade kids make a lot of decisions.
They don't realize you're going to take
them down one promising path or down a
bad path,
but I digress.
the point is that I view interviewing as
a tool in the toolkit for extracting
specific details and tactics that I can
then impart to my readers who are I
guess my students in this case for
replicating excellent results.
That's it.
So I'm,
I'm trying to tease oUt the cliff notes
and interviewing,
askIng good questions,
asking good follow up questions,
letting silence do the work at very
specific points is how you extract that
gold and without the ability to
interview.
Well,
I can't do the research that I need to
do and the podcast.
I never expected to do anything.
Uh,
it was really a commitment just to doing
six episodes so that I wouldn't quit.
I made that public pronouncement do at
least six episodes so that I'd be held
accountable and I want it to work on
improving verbal ticks.
I wanted to improve the selection and
follow up related to questions and to
become a more active listener because I
knew that even if the podcast cratered
or I didn't like it and I quit,
those were skills that would transfer
everywhere else and this is something
that I actually borrowed a ultimately
and really developed after Scott Adams
of dilbert fame and calls it systems
thinking instead of goals thinkIng,
but thinking of how you can win even if
your project fails and the way you do
that is by focusing on developing skills
and relationships that transcend that
and persist over time.
So that's really how I thought about it
and why I got into the audio game.
but I was burned out on books,
on,
to take a break from big books.
And here we are.
Yeah,
I hear that.
I'm curious on the,
on the followup question.
I got a follow up for you,
which is how,
how scientific is that for you?
So if you have a follow up prepared,
someone hands you the answer that
basically you expected,
do you always go to that follow up or
how willing are you to go out there?
Because I find that to be a constant
battle sort of of me wanting to just
have the natural flow of a conversation
versus I also want to hit on certain
things.
I don't want to let theM off the hook on
certain things.
I let people hang themselves.
That's my method instead of shouting
them down.
I think that's a little more of your
method as well,
which is what I'm doing with you right
now.
very subtly.
Oh yeah.
No,
I feel like like an invisible midget is
strangling me at the moment on my back,
her naked choking me,
but no,
the.
The,
the question I think has very personal
answers in,
and the reason I say that is if you
study some of the people best known for
asking questions,
say Larry King.
Larry king very often goes in doing next
to no homework on his guests.
The rationale being that the guest has
no familiarity,
I'm sorry,
the audience has no familiarity with the
guest and he wants to start from where
they are and asking the basic questions.
Then you have,
say a james lipton of inside the actors
studio.
he has every question scripted in
advance and he never deviates from his
order of questions.
Period.
End of story.
He knows the answer in some form to
every question he's going to ask,
so you have them on opposite ends of the
spectrum.
In my case,
I don't necessarily have set followup
questions,
but I do have a handful of questions
which I've borrowed from other people
that very often can turn a mediocre
answer or a decent answer into a great
answer with a few extra details and
layers.
So you might have somebody ask them a
question,
they respond and then you say,
what did you learn from that super easy
follow up question?
You can ask almost any time,
right?
How did that make you feel?
That's another really easy one.
That is kind of a layup oftentimes and
uh,
I don't go in with a completely set
agenda.
I'll give you an example.
When I was interviewing margaret cho,
comedian,
I thought we were going to talk about.
We've got her next week,
so this is going to be good for me.
Oh,
she's awesome.
She's awesome.
She's great.
So,
so we were talking about the craft of
comedy and so on and handling hecklers
and so on.
You should ask her about that and we,
but we ended up bringing up and touching
on addiction in comedy,
drug addiction specifically in that,
that took us to a really place and if I
had been stuck on script we wouldn't
have explored it and that ended up being
just an incredibly fertile ground for
discussion.
So I try not to Be too fixed,
uh,
but I do have my pet questions that I
like to ask as we all do.
Yeah.
Have you ever been offended by a guess?
That's one of the things that people ask
me a lot,
that how can I sit with someone who
maybe is against gay marriage and I'm
gay man,
how can I sit with them and even if I
hear their rationale and their not being
mean to me specifically,
how can I tolerate that conversation?
And to me it's like I may not like it,
but I do have to.
The whole point of an interview is to
try to understand why someone thinks
that someone ever said something they
truly offended you.
I'm sure they have.
Nothing's jumping to mind.
Uh,
but I'm sure that that's the case and it
makes me think a bit of advice that I
got from stephen dubner,
author of freakonomics or coauthor,
at least he collaborates with steven
levin in this,
uh,
the.
I kind of went into a few different
aspects of this in tools of titans,
but he said it's very important to put
away your moral compass in the beginning
when you're trying to problem solve.
Especially when you're collaborating
with other people.
It doesn't mean that you absolve
yourself of moral decisions and
judgments.
But Initially,
if you,
if you want to put,
if you want to generate as many possible
solutions,
including non obvious solutions or
lateral thinking solutions that you want
to take the constraints and assumptions
that you live with all day long and try
to set them to the side.
When I'm interviewing someone,
uh,
let's say,
could be Glenn Beck,
right?
I live in san francisco.
Uh,
if I'm interviewing Glenn Beck,
if I'm interviewing a,
well,
let's just say general stanley
mcchrystal or jocko willink.
So both from a extensive military
backgrounds versus someone who might
view themselves as a extremely,
let's say hyper progressive slash
liberal pacifist while they're going to
have opposing viewpoints on a lot of
things.
But what,
what my ivy job as extracting
politically neutral a or a political
routines and habits and so on that
people can use.
So one of the mistakes I think that we
as humans tend to make is that we throw
the baby out with the bathwater.
We say,
well,
I disagree with so and so on x.
So I'm going to.
I'm going to assume they have nothing to
offer me.
and that's a huge mistake and it's a
very costly mistakes.
So whenever I'm talking to someone,
I have some of my friends I disagree
with,
vehemently about let's say nine out of
10 of their core beliefs,
let's just call them political beliefs,
but as long as they will engage in a
debate and not try to shut it down with
name calling and nonsense,
if,
if they're willing to dance with that
and spar and admit when they've.
If they are able to absorb new
information and consider new evidence
and change their viewpoints accordingly.
In some cases I have no problem spending
time with those people and in in fact,
I think one of the biggest mistakes we
were talking about echo chambers and
silicon valley's,
that if you surround yourself with
people who hold all the same opinions
that you do well,
you're going to get very comfortable
with comfort.
But it's not going to force you to
consider,
say,
devil's advocate positions that are
diametrically opposed to your own.
And I think that's incredibly valuable
practice.
And some of my friends are the first
people to call bs.
Even in a group setting.
At a dinner like,
like novel robuchon I love the guy,
uh,
and I feel better.
I feel every conversation we have,
I come out of having improved in some
way.
You'll be the first person to call me
out if I throw out some position or,
or strong stance without evidence and
rationale to back it up.
Yeah.
So,
and don't you relish in that?
I mean,
I think I love it.
I love it.
I think most people truly do and somehow
we've sort of been tricked or dumbed
down to the point where we think if
anything goes a little against us that
we have to lash out.
And that's so not,
that's so not fertile ground for,
for growth.
No,
I agree.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that one of the things I try to
do a at least once a week,
but preferably much more than this is to
be the weakest person in the room at
something where I want to be in the room
and it's going to lead me probably to
feel insecure,
maybe insufficient,
but whether it's training in a sport or
picking up a new skill or sitting down
in a room where people are discussing
could be anything molecular biology or
politics where I feel like I'm in over
my head and that is how you average up
and I think you also average up by
surrounding yourself with people who can
intelligently debate and not just use
rhetoric to try to corner people,
but to actually go toe to toe with
logical arguments at least based on
their own assumptions.
I think that's.
If you want to become smarter and by the
way like the race doesn't go to the
well.
The fittest in this situation means most
adaptable and I think that is the
cornerstone of everything else.
Yeah.
What do you make of this new idea that
everyone seems to think that they have
to have an opinion on everything?
Like if you look at Russia right now,
whatever is going on with Russia and the
election,
we don't have to get into the minutia of
it,
but it seems to me that people who I've
never seen talk about Russia before,
who I don't think are particularly
informed or smart.
Everybody's got an opinion and must
share that opinion.
I'm for the free speech part.
They do whatever they want,
but just this idea that everyone always
has to share everything.
Yeah.
I mean they.
They probably couldn't place rush on a
map.
Yeah,
so the,
the,
the great gift and curse of the internet
is that everyone has a voice now that
means every smart people,
every smart person as voice also means
every idiot has a voice and a more and
more,
and this is in part because I go out of
my way to expose myself to people who
knew more about many,
many domains than myself.
I find myself.
It's not pleading the fifth.
It's different.
I will say,
I don't think I'm qualified to have an
opinion on this.
I say that in the last few years,
my,
the frequency of me saying that has just
skyrocketed,
uh,
because I don't want to have a strong
opinion where I can't back it up.
And so I think that it's fine to have an
informed opinion,
but there's informed confidence and then
there's uninformed cubistic stupidity.
Um,
so I,
I try,
I would hope that people would lean more
towards the farmer and away from the
ladder,
but alas,
in,
in a,
in a media culture where the eyeballs
and ears tend to gravitate to the most
outlandish argument imaginable.
Uh,
it seems that that tends to get a lot of
the attention.
Yeah.
Are you ever tempted by that,
that click portion of this,
you know,
we know very easily we could title are
things differently and probably triple
the clicks.
We could use mismeeting thumbnails.
I mean know all the games of the digital
world.
Plenty of people are playing.
Have you ever been tempted to do any of
that stuff?
You know,
I,
in the beginning,
I mean when I had my first blog and if
people out there want to laugh their
asses off,
they can look up just google tim ferriss
first blog.
It is the most hideous disorganized,
terrible mess you've ever seen on the
internet.
It's,
it's really atrocious.
And at the time I was told I had to
mimic this person and how they did x.
I had to do 12 posts a day before noon
to have any hope of ab and c it was
there,
all these arbitrary rules and it was a
me too game of mimicry.
So I did try listicles and all sorts of
stuff that on some level works,
but it wasn't me and it had no evergreen
value.
So I've,
I've been rewarded thankfully for trying
to put together a really comprehensive
material that lasts not only last
multiple years,
but the real estate,
if we're talking about print,
let's say actually goes up over time.
So my,
my,
my google real estate appreciates over
time and some of my most popular posts
were written five,
six years ago and they still drive the
majority of traffic to my blog.
So I have been tempted at points to do
that.
But ultimately my fans,
oh,
I'm very fortunate,
very smart,
generally very well educated.
They are very vocal.
So if I try to pull any of those
shenanigans,
I get punished very quickly for that.
So it's um,
it's good to be held accountable.
Yeah,
I,
I feel the same way.
So we're uh,
we're in good company.
I suppose.
What about just sort of the general
feeling right now that the media
companies,
twitter and youtube and google that
there is some sort of censorshIp
happening related to either algorithms
or you know,
banning certain people like twitter for
example,
they banned milo.
Uh,
but you know,
they'll have,
you know,
the richard spencers on there and
verified.
Again,
you don't have to comment on the
specifics of that,
but just the general,
like these companies are so close to
government right now.
and this is our information highway
right here.
This is a toughie.
This is where I might use that line that
I mentioned.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I see.
He set me up with it.
Yeah.
But it's not because I couldn't have an
opinion,
but I feel like I,
I would have an obligation to actually
sit down with people who work at
facebook,
twitter and these places because I know
a lot of people in all of these
companies and have a real factual
discussion about what's going on.
Um,
at this point,
I do think at the very least,
if we're going to deal with bending or
preventing certain types of people from
voicing their opinions,
there should be a consIstent playing
field,
right?
It shouldn't be moving goalposts and so
the rules should be clear from the
outset and they should apply to everyone
and there shouldn't be one off
exceptions.
Uh,
I think in most cases when we get into
algorithms and what is rewarded and what
is not,
there are always unintended consequences
of a,
the best design.
Whether that is an algorithm or if
there's an incentive structure,
right?
I mean,
if you incentivize any of your workers,
let's say within an organization with
certain types of sales quotas and
bonuses and so on,
there are always going to be sort of
perverse side effects of those
incentives.
That's always the case.
So I think that it's,
in a way,
it's,
it's on one hand,
rational and important that we have high
standards for how people,
uh,
how people serve and curate data so that
we're not proliferating fake news and
that,
that can't be used as a weapon of
propaganda in a very damaging capacity
simultaneously.
I think it's unreasonable to expect that
all of these gigantic companies we're
dealing with technology and platforms
have a that is incomprehensible to most
people who aren't sitting down and being
shown what it looks like on some level
by say,
an employee of google.
It's,
it's hard to even fathom what being
google means.
So it's unfair to expect them to get all
the details right all the time.
It's an evolving system,
so they're,
they're gonna make mistakes,
uh,
and it's good to hold them to a high
standard but difficult to expect
perfection as they try to improve it.
Um,
so,
so that I would,
uh,
I would put safely in the category of,
I'm going to reserve judgment until I
have more information.
I think that was a pretty solid answer
for reserving judgment.
I mean,
you still gave me something there.
How do you decide who to trust when you,
when you're getting your information,
you're talking to people from,
I mean,
in your case,
quite literally every walk of life
probably that there is.
How do you decide who or what or what
news organization or whatever else that
you actually feel is doing a fair,
impartial job?
Uh,
I don't trust organizations in general,
um,
but I will try to identify specific
people and if I'm really trying to do
triage,
I will identify people in my circle of
friends are in my network who may not be
specialists in the domain that I'm
looking at,
whether that's a cancer research or
fill in the blank,
a san francisco local politics.
And,
and how to most effect change with a
given proposition.
It could be super specific.
I will reach out to two or three of my
friends who I think will have already
tried to vet a good sources of
information or simply good thinking.
So it could be people who are good at
interpreting the information.
People were acting as,
as human aggregators and filters.
Oh,
almost go out immediately to those
people.
For instance.
Uh,
I very frequently bump into people.
I'm excited.
I'm reasonably involved with,
uh,
both current and former military.
So I've,
I've spent time at the defense language
institute in monterey,
certainly have a lot of friends who were
former military and you bump into a lot
of folks running around calling
themselves navy seals and a lot of them
are
exaggerating what they've done.
There are some very,
very legitimate folks.
And then there are a lot of people who
drive the legitimate folks crazy because
all they actually did was passed buds,
were never deployed.
Now they're running around selling navy
seal workout routines and getting book
deals.
Right?
So if in a case like that,
I will immediately go to two or three of
my friends were from that community and
say,
hey,
sniff test zero to 10,
how would you recommend I talk to this
person?
So it's a very hands on process.
I start from effectively a place of
distrust with,
with any mass media because the
incentives are not aligned with truth at
all costs.
They just are not.
And,
and unfortunately,
that's,
I think the reality of the business
models of,
of many of these,
uh,
companies.
So even the individual participants,
however much they may want to represent
difficult or to divulge and discuss
difficult truths are disincentivized
from doing so because it may be so
nuanced that only five percent of the
target audience will take the time to
understand it and discuss it.
But when you're trying to monetize on a
cpm basis,
the number of slideshows you can put on
a website then a,
you run into,
you run into a conflict very quickly.
Uh,
yeah.
So that's unfortunate challenge of,
of,
uh,
trying to siphon news.
Another thing that I'll use,
and I've no affiliation with this,
this is a program called nuzzel and use
these eel and what that will do is it
will aggregate the most shared stories
from the people I follow on twitter and
it creates a digest of say the top 10
stories that have been shared the most
by the people I have already selected to
follow and I've found that very useful,
but it in at any point,
for instance right now or near
presidential elections really within six
months on either side,
it's just 99 percent noise,
but at other periods it can be a very,
very useful source of pre-filtered
information from folks I've already
handpicked to follow on say twitter.
So for pattern matching,
uh,
that's been,
that's been very helpful for me.
Yeah,
it's funny because I expected and hoped
that after the election we'd have like a
little bit of a low with politics one
way or another and it's almost like
everything has just been ramped up even
more.
I'm curious when you talk about,
you know,
picking some people that you trust and
things like that,
uh,
you are also from long island and I've
mentioned on the show a couple of times
before that one of my great joys over
the course of the election is that I was
involved in a group text with three of
my old childhood from middle school
friends and we sort of reconnected over
politics arguing all the time.
One of the guys was a huge trump guy.
One was a huge bernie guy.
One was somewhere in between and then me
and I thought this,
these are people I trust.
Like I knew them from childhood.
I know where they come from.
I knew theIr family,
celebrated holidays with them,
all of that stuff.
Do you do have a couple of people in
your life like that
who I have completely diverging
opinions?
Well,
diverging opinions,
but also that you have,
you have the long history from childhood
that you,
that maybe are outside of what you do
normally that you can go to and be like,
oh yeah,
what do you think about stuff?
You know?
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
Absolutely.
I mean I just came back from a bachelor
party for one of my oldest friends I've
known since we were kids and a very
eclectic group of guys who got to know
one another before anyone was really
entrenched in a given career or anything
like that.
And it's very refreshing to have a,
I think in healthy to have those friends
who really don't have,
there's no potential or at least i don't
think so would these guys certainly not
any type of ulterior motive or
professional motivation.
There's just none of that bs and noise
and static and nonsense.
Uh,
so yes,
I do.
I do have those folks for sure.
Yeah.
How do you deal with that part of it
that because of the nature of what you
do and the public persona around you,
people want things from you all the
time.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
they do.
Uh,
and it's a tax that I've accepted I have
to pay and it,
I think it would be unreasonable for me
to complain about it since it is a
byproduct of public exposure,
which I've opted into,
but it can be frustrating.
I mean there are times when people will
approach me and it,
and they'll try to butter me up for a
few weeks and do me a bike.
It's always a tip off when I start
getting a lot of unsolicited favors from
someone who doesn't want anything.
And I'm like,
I bet you're going to send me a book in
two weeks that I don't want to read with
the expectation that I'm going to give
you a blurb.
I bet that's what's going to happen.
And lo and behold,
that's exactly what happens.
So I've had to set policies that allow
me to turn off entire categories of
requests.
Like I don't do book forwards.
I don't do book blurbs.
I don't do fill in the blank across the
board a hundred percent just don't do
it.
And,
uh,
every once in a blue moon,
I'll make an exception for someone I
know really well,
but it's very,
very rare,
uh,
or for instance,
right now,
like I'm not doing startup investing.
So if you think you're gonna come to a
conference and talk to me about two or
three things you found on my wikipedia
page to try to develop some rapport and
then pitch me or startup at the end of
the night.
Not going to happen.
Oh man,
I was going to hit you up because,
you know,
we're growing pretty rapidly here,
but a little seed money,
you know what I'm saying?
And that happens all the time.
It's unbelievable.
I mean,
I've had,
I've had people in san francisco,
this is very unique to the,
uh,
somewhat like asperger's romanticizing
niche nature of silicon valley.
But I mean,
I've had people I'm sitting at a dinner
with say a girlfriend and they will
literally come up,
pull up a chair,
sit down and just start pitching apropos
of nothing.
No intro,
no nothing.
I had one guy at south by southwest,
uh,
I've had at least 12 guys try to pitch
me while I'm standing at a urinal,
which is the right time,
not a good elevator pitch you at that
point.
It doesn't matter how
good your pitches and it goes on,
but I would say it's a text that,
that I've had to accept.
Um,
but I,
I,
I'm,
I'm much more cautious about any open
ended invite to have a conversation or a
coffee or a dinner.
So if someone says,
hey,
can I introduce you to my friend joe?
He wants to grab a cup of coffee or like
we'd love to come to dinner with us.
I'm like,
okay,
if joe wanted something from me,
what would it be?
What would you guess?
And I want to know in advance,
like it's okay to have a pitch,
but I want to know what it is
beforehand.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's,
that's how I think of it these days.
All right,
well let's,
let's finish up by actually talking
about your new book.
Are you willing to talk about your new
book?
I am willing.
I know twist,
twist the arm,
but I'll go for it.
All right.
Let's see What we can do here.
so a tool to tighten.
So this is basically the collection of
the best ideas,
the best practices that some of the most
interesting people that you've talked to
over the past couple of years have put
into practice.
So I guess the easiest question at first
would be is there,
is there just the general theme with
these heavy hitters,
with these people who are doing it that
we all would want to emulate and be like
and learn from is what is the.
What is the general theme?
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll answer that.
And I would say also that in tools of
titans is really never intended to be a
book.
It was just a notebook that I was
compiling for my own use,
so it was going back over my own notes
to grab the most actionable routines and
tools,
gadgets,
anything that I could apply immediately
and test from all of these different
guests.
and one of the themes I would say that
that first it's split into three
sections,
and this is how a lot of these guests
think about their lives,
healthy,
wealthy,
and wise,
and the healthiest first because the
most prolific thinkers and creatives in
the book have also come to highly
prioritize physical function and uh,
that manifests in a lot of ways.
But for instance,
rick rubin,
one of the most legendary music
traditionalist of the last 50 years,
introduced me to something called the
chilly pad,
which I won't get too far into it,
but allows you to very precisely set the
temperature of the sheet that you lay on
your bed.
And it's been a complete game changer
for me and many other people.
And that also came up with super
athletes.
So you find a lot of commonalities in
the top.
One percent have multiple fields.
In other words,
they have more in common,
even though it might be chess,
military strategist,
black market chemists,
you name it,
the,
the top one percent.
And all of those fields have a lot in
common more so than they have in common
with the b players.
In their own fields,
so that was really cool to see all of
them,
I would say are very good at asking
seemingly absurd questions.
So,
so that that is a commonality across the
whole,
the whole gang.
So you would have say there are a bunch
of billionaires in the book like the
reid hoffman's and peter teals and marc
andreessen's there.
There are a lot of folks.
A peter teal I think is a very good
example.
So he asks questions like,
and I'm paraphrasing,
but why can't you accomplish your 10
year plan in the next six months?
Right.
All right.
That's,
that's a very bold question and if
you're going to think on that and as
many people in this book do journal on
it and actually sit down and freehand on
that question for three pages,
let's just say,
then you have to temporarily put aside
the constraints and assumptions that
have led you to where you are.
Because if it's your 10 year plan,
you've set a timeframe and sort of an
incremental approach that doesn't work
at all if you're trying to cram it into
six months.
So all of a sudden you have to come up
with these very,
very potentially outlandish and absurd
unconventional answers.
And uh,
what,
what I have found also in these two go
together is that a.
So for instance,
Larry Page co founder of google has
said,
and I'm going to paraphrase this,
but what people miss about really big
audacious goals is that it's hard to
fail completely.
So you'll very often fail above everyone
else's success even if it's only a
partial when I'm.
So you find a lot of that.
Like peter diamandis,
chairman of the xprize is working on all
these different exponential technologies
and spends a lot of time with people
like ray kurzweil,
James Cameron and so on.
When entrepreneurs are pitching him to
try to get investment,
he will ask them,
and I'm paraphrasing all of these,
but if you had to 10 x the economics of
your business in the next three months,
what would you do?
And if their response is,
that's impossible.
He responds with,
I don't accept that answer.
TrY again.
And so,
but,
but to get unusual output and to find
paths that are unique,
that are not well trodden,
you have to ask better questions.
So I'd saY that's very,
very common.
More than 80 percent of the people in
the book also have some type of
mindfulness practice which could take
the form of meditation,
say using a guided meditation.
There's one that came up a few times,
which is free,
called the,
the 2010 summer smile meditation,
which is by tara brock.
Super specific.
But that one came up multiple times for
instance,
or people using headspace in the
mornings.
Arnold schwartzenegger ended up using
transcendental meditation for a year
twice a day and then saw benefits for
decades afterwards,
which is really wild when you think
about it.
Uh,
other commonalities.
So I asked almost all of the guests,
what have you gifted most to other
people?
Yeah,
there are certain books that popped up
over and over again that are maybe
lesser known,
like poor charlie's almanack by charlie
munger,
who's warren buffet's right hand man.
But who gets less of the media
spotlight?
Because I think he quite frankly hates
being in the spotlight.
He'S pretty cantankerous dude,
but an Incredible book that came up
repeatedly with some of the wealthiest
people.
A siddhartha by herman hesse,
came up repeatedly by some of the best
musicians and investors go figure.
Right?
So there are sapiens was another one
that came up across the board
repeatedly.
So these are the types of things that
you spot.
There's some weird ones like,
um,
males over the age of say,
45,
a very high percentage of them don't eat
breakfast at all or only eat one primary
meal per day,
usually early dinner.
That came up a lot.
So you have,
that's totally conventional wisdom,
right?
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's for the most part runs completely
counter to conventional wisdom.
But if you look into the scientific
literature,
which I've done a even for females,
it looks,
it appears as though there's some data
to suggest that as you get older you
actually consume protein,
for instance,
better in a single large bolus,
a single large dose.
So rather than having like a
bodybuilder,
a meal every four hours or whatever it
is,
even three meals a day,
if you're a 70 year old,
80 year old,
you will actually consume your protein
more efficiently,
having the majority in one meal and go
figure.
So it seems to,
seems to correspond,
but there's a bunch of weird stuff like
that that pops up over and over.
Have any of these titans told,
knew something or given you some wisdom
that you tried to put into practice?
And then we're like,
man,
that does not work for me.
Uh,
well,
uh,
yes,
definitely.
Uh,
and,
and the good news is for every pattern,
there's someone who will let you off the
hook.
That's,
that's,
that's the good news.
So you can really,
the objective is,
is to create your own bespoke toolkit.
Right?
And for instance,
there are a lot of people who wake up
very early.
You have people,
amelia boone,
who is this incredible super athlete,
jocko willink,
a long list of folks who wake up at say
4:30
in the morning.
So I've tried that,
but I'm much better going to bed around
4:30
in the morning and uh,
so I would lean more towards say,
the bj novak said,
you know,
writers and comedians and so on who
can't even really hit their groove until
11:00
AM.
That's more my speed.
But yeah,
the,
the waking up with the amish,
not my thing.
I can't,
I can't really make that work for me.
Not,
not anytime soon.
So do you think some of this is just how
you're hardwired
versus how you can actually learn to
train yourself?
Like something like that.
I would guess that knowing you,
you could probably overcome that if you
put enough time into it.
You may not feel that that's worthy of
putting time into,
but how much is that battle between just
the way you're hardwired in nature
versus the desire to change yourself?
Well,
I think you've,
I think you can see the good news is
that everything in tools of titans is
intended to be a one day or one week
experiment,
right?
So you can try it.
And uh,
as Bruce Lee said,
something along these lines,
he said,
except what is useful,
reject,
what is useless,
add what is uniquely your own.
So I've tried to do the morning thing
and I'm just better,
yeah,
going to bed late and waking up late and
uh,
I,
I'm okay with that.
I've accepted that.
I don't beat myself up over it.
And uh,
there is definitely a hard wiring
component.
I mean,
some people need only three hours of
sleep per night.
I know a bunch of these mutants,
the vast majority of people will do best
on say seven and a half to 10 hours of
sleep per night.
And I would say maybe 30 percent of the
people I've spoken to that I've talked
to about this,
we'll try to get some type of short nap
in the say mid afternoon between 2:30
and 4:00.
So it's,
it's,
there are certain personalized elements,
uh,
that are dependent on your genetic
makeup or at least,
uh,
influenced by your genetic makeup.
But I mean,
in reality is more negotiable than I
think people realize.
Even that stuff,
you can override it if you want to for
periods of time,
you can,
you can use something like polyphasic
sleep and combine that with something
called exoticness ketones.
IT's powdered form of alternate energy.
Basically you combine those two things
that you could probably do like two,
two and half hours of sleep per day for
a few weeks at a time and I've done that
before in dire situations,
but it's not something you want to try
to sustain
for.
Man.
I should've,
I should've talked to you about a month
ago because I couldn't use it with bud.
Alright.
I'm going to end this with the most
softball question of all time.
If you had one book that you wanted
people to go out and read right now,
go out and buy a book,
you know what I mean?
Digital hard copy,
whatever it is.
What book would that be?
I would,
I would have to recommend not biased.
Uh,
I would have to recommend tools of
titans because this is the first book I
enjoyed writing and it is the first book
that I have since writing re-read
multiple times because the,
the tools and tactics and
recommendations are not just mine.
It's not me listening to myself.
This is the best practices of 200 world
class performance from every possible
discipline you can imagine.
and um,
as of right now on amazon,
I think it has 410 reviews straight.
I mean it's a five star average.
It's like 87 percent have given it five
stars.
Come on.
I think.
I know you're refreshing as we're
talking.
I'm come on now.
Oh yeah,
no,
the compulsive amazon check.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
there's no author.
Well,
I shouldn't say no other,
no other.
I know who is immune to that during
launch week for sure.
You having that level of peace yet,
you know,
have high level nothing yet.
No.
During launch week,
yeah.
Every author is just like a rat with a
cocaine pellet dispenser checking amazon
if we're being honest.
But yeah,
tools of titans is what I'd recommend.
It's,
it's,
uh,
I think very appropriate for all age
levels,
incredibly flexible gift.
There's something in it for everybody
and it's really intended so that you can
sit down with a cup of tea or coffee and
get a chapter in that period of time,
but the time you finished that cub.
So it's a,
it's a fun book and a very proud of it.
So if people feel so inclined,
I would,
I would encourage them to check out
tools of titans.
All right,
well,
you know what we're gonna do,
we're gonna put the link to tools to tie
it in the comment thing right down
below.
And we will see if the dave rubin effect
is as powerful as the tim paris.
I can't wait.
Can't wait to see it.
And people can keep.
People can find retailers all over the
world if they want or you know,
amazon.
So on,
at tools of titans.com.
There also some sample chapters forward
from arnold schwarzenegger.
It's wild.
Um,
so yes,
we will,
we will see,
we will see what happens.
I,
I'm looking forward to it.
All right man.
Well listen,
we did a.
I think we did over an hour here and I
know you only have a four hour work
week.
Very appreciative of your time.
You're welcome.
My pleasure,
man.
AlrigHt,
thanks to tim ferriss,
you guys can follow him on twitter at
tim ferriss.
The link for tools of titans is right
down below and thanks for watching.
We'll do it again next week.